joe sweet joe how's it going i'm good
i'm rachel nice to see you
nice to see you as well nice to meet you
you are looking short mister
thank you very much loving that papa
blue thanks yeah
a little free guy blew in there yeah why
not right that's on this film it really
is a fun ride
you know kind of looks at people looking
at themselves in an alternate universe a
gaming universe so if you could select
anyone from hollywood
to be your avatar who would it be
joe not someone from this movie no no no
i'd probably have to say
rocky sly stallone probably the first
okay yeah yeah yeah i'm just mad at that
legendary
absolutely legendary something else
legendary
and one for the books stranger things
what can we ent we have been waiting for
season four
because of the pandemic what can fans
expect
you know i just wrapped up my own stuff
so we're getting close this show's still
going but um
yeah we're getting there i think it's
gonna i think it's really gonna be worth
the wait
um obviously kind of my hands are tied
can't really say too much stuff but like
i'm very excited um and
it continues to excite you now that
you've been this character for
four seasons strong now because it you
know could it could become old hat but
it could become something new that
evolves it's just the people you know i
love the people that we make the show
with and the brothers and the cast
obviously and shawn
and it's just something i really look
forward to going back and seeing
everybody and being presented with a new
challenge each year when you get to
read the scripts and see what's kind of
in store for you yeah it's you know
i'll never have another experience like
it i can imagine so i'm really just
soaking it up and loving it it'll be sad
it'll be sad when it's over but when it
when are we anticipating that hopefully
yeah we need to
soak that up as much as we can as well
as the cameos in this film can i tell
you
i was like what is that i know right i
know it was so exciting there are great
ones in this
some really fun ones can you tease to
the fans
one cameo that you think is just gonna
blow their mind i mean there's one at
the end
there's two at the end that are
incredible
i can't really say much but there's some
really great
music um that goes along with the both
of them so
another one is some great dancing for
one of the uh
that makes the camera i wasn't even
thinking about that one that one's
amazing
yeah he's kind of two times the cameo he
shows up a couple times
so we got you guys on the edge of your
seats right now